President Trump says he will cancel a
weekend visit to Poland to focus on the
storm people across Florida are waiting
in long lines for hours at stores and
gas stations to get supplies our lead
national correspondent David Pegg now is
in Merritt Island near Cape Canaveral
David how long have those people been
waiting on those lines well some people
showed up about 45 minutes ago they
weren't gonna start serving sandbags
again today until 8 a.m. but some people
said I brought my shovel and so I'm
gonna start serving myself that lady's
loading some sandbags into her vehicle
right now here's the sandbag pile you
can understand why people would be
taking it upon themselves some folks
waiting in line for 8 hours yesterday
you just you just your husband waited
yesterday you just got here so that's
what people are doing not only here but
up and down the state at various sandbag
locations and we've seen lines not only
for sand but for food water and fuel as
the intensifying hurricane Dorian
prepares to make landfall in Florida
people here are racing to get ready
better safe than sorry there are long
lines extending outside grocery stores
shelves once filled with bread water are
now empty some stores have been telling
people they can only have four cases of
water per family I want to fill up my
tank so that when it's time to go I'll
go there are lines at gas stations that
stretch all the way down the interstate
in Davie Florida near Miami we can't
tell you exactly where this thing is
gonna go right now it's been kind of
here and there but even with so much
uncertainty I think I'm gonna get 10
bags but I'll take what I can get some
people here in Brevard County near
Orlando spent nearly eight hours in line
waiting for sandbags Jamie Pannell is
worried that water will flood her home
by coming in the back door so she waited
in a very long line with her 7 month-old
daughter Mackenzie how long you been in
Lyons 6 hours
but it's like victory now so it was
worth it I have to tell you no one work
that we've seen so far is panicking
people are calm they are orderly but
they are preparing right now the
governor says you got to do it now don't
wait until tomorrow get it done that's
why Teresa is here Gail doing her own
sandbags so she doesn't have to wait
seven or eight hours like Jamie did yes
give her a hand David she actually asked
and I said well let me finish the report
then I'll uh I hope you out and you know
what I know you're gonna do that too but
you're right panicking never helps thank
you David very much